après tu es fort de jeu je vous le dis
je regarde c'est ludivine les matchs les
bugs et là c'est lord c'est une cure des
missions au baba c'est quoi ton histoire
outils refus ya que toi pour faire ça
cyril battait tout mais on fait partout
salut mon damasceno alors comme ça tu
vas faire 35 heures de télé non stop
sans service en faire caca s'endormir
bah écoute bravo parce que là ça va être
compliqué mais je sais que tu vas gérer
parce que c'est pour l'année
et toi le meilleur animateur du parc
dalle-dumont si je suis de tout coeur
avec toi je te fais des gros gros gros
gros gros gros gros bisous courage
courage courage on y croit on y croise
chercher je te souhaite bonne chance
pour des 35 heures
il n'oublie pas de biais et hydrate et
c'est très important et pense aussi à
des fruits parce qu'elle débite ami si
tu as besoin d'un coach pour bien bouger
ton record mondial je te souhaite bonne
chance
c'est long 35 heures courage les amiens
bravo pour ce que vous faites vous
envoie toute ma force je suis tout coeur
avec vous et un grand malade de faire 35
heures d'émissions en tout cas j'espère
qu'il va battre le record te souhaite
bon courage à tous et toute l'équipe
vous fais plein de bisous
après je te tue
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
vivable
oui
[Applaudissements]
et
l'échec on a préparé un petit feu
d'artifice pour fêter ses 35 heures je
vais vous demander à tous de sortir avec
moi venez vous allez voir a préparé de
la crise ouvert mercier le public d'être
venus aussi nombreux vers si les séries
c'est pas tout à fait terminé venez avec
moi
on vous a préparé un feu d'artifice chez
vous vous allez kiffer parce que il ya
que dans cette émission qu'on préfère ça
vraiment je voudrais vous remercier et
remercier tous les gens qui m'ont
soutenu jean marc simon loïc à qui lui a
passé
loric 35 heures devant sa télé a tous
regardé donc mololo j'espère que t'as
kiffé bien sûr diego aussi qui
m'accompagne partout
toute la famille bien sûr qui m'a
soutenu tous les amis attention rien il
est chef derrière merci voilà les chéris
un petit feu d'artifice qui est mise en
place mon humour bravo bravo à toutes
les équipes
bien sûr toutes les équipes de sécurité
toutes les équipes de régie bien sûr mon
vincent plus jeune qui a fait aussi un
travail fabuleux comme d'habitude et qui
est toujours là pour nous voilà merci
mon mokhtar aussi les chéris il ya un
peu d'artifices qui va démarrer tout de
suite alors ça dès mardi
c'est quoi c'est là un feu d'artifice
pour fêter les 35 heures je vous dis feu
d'artifice
charlotte bravo ma chérie également à
boé mon juge lui aussi superbe nourdine
aussi les chérit le feu d'artifice parce
que philippe stoltz le directeur général
est toujours adoré que marx et pour vous
c'est pour lui 35 regarder ce qu'on
appelle paris c'est magnifique c'est bon
on est pendante comme des cons j'adore
moi c'est ça ces deux installations
sakho bien ce à quoi je venais ses
collègues
j'aimerais remercier mon camille combal
mon chéri d'amour à tous légalement tous
les producteurs stéphanie loire mme sy
voilà qui embrasse fort j'en profite
pour remercier encore des gens bien sûr
sandra qui étaient avec nous aussi
l'inversé capucines à la merci maca plus
que j'aime qu est également et sa part
pas pour l'instant on est dans la merde
et un feu d'artifice qui doit partir
d'un instant à l'autre
voilà je préfère vous le dire donc reste
avec nous parce que quand ça va partir
ça va péter ça va péter fort je vous le
dis je remerciais ludivine les mecs les
mecs c'est la salade prélevé le hardware
débat de l'émission d'actions
le ratage total bull loyer ses 35 e
regarder je vois aussi beaucoup de
capitaux j'ai remarqué la stéphanie et
fanny l'algérie voilà elle c'est un
amour merci merci beaucoup
vraiment
merci à tout ça je me garde juin à sebha
soria nicosie qui m'ont suffi
merci les chéris on va regarder l'un est
là je crois qu'on peut dire qu'on l'a
fait les 35 heures c'était merci monica
merci à tous et merci
mais pas tous les gars encore la
patience
[Musique]
l'affairé des quotas pour de nouvelles
avancées on aura dormi ici la merci
[Musique]